if you allow anyone to say that they are
whichever sex they choose you will end
up moving rapists into women's jails
like that's just like a theorem you know
and it doesn't even take very many steps
and I thought as soon as I said that to
somebody who said trans women or women
that I said to them yeah but if that's
the case then we will end up putting
rapists in women's jails they would go
oh yeah I didn't think about that
turns out they don't
turns out people don't give a [ __ ]
they don't care about prisoners I think
I don't think it's They Don't Care About
Women particularly in his prisoners so
it's a black box prisons are black
boxers you don't see what goes on inside
them but you're pretty sure pretty
terrible things go on inside them
and there's an undertone of what those
people deserve it and not always just an
undertone I mean even people who think
of themselves as good liberal people who
believe in the rule of law and so on
will say that you know a pedophile
deserves what he gets in prison
that surprised me because I don't think
that I believe in the rule of law I
think you know we have a justice system
because we don't want that sort of
extrajudicial way of thinking about
things I'm sorry I just don't think it's
right
and then when you think about women in
prison you don't even need to be
thinking about the arguments about
whether Peter falls deserve what they
get in prison because women in prison
are so unlike men in prison
like one day I looked at the statistics
and I thought you know there is nowhere
you will see the difference between men
and women more
except on the maternity ward
so if you look at prisons right nearly
all prisoners I'm in like 96 or
something like that
and of those about a fifth of sex
offenders so you've got tens of
thousands of violent prisoners who are
men and maybe 20 000-ish or fifteen
thousand ish who are in for a sex
offense now we know that most rapes
don't get reported we know that even the
ones that get reported don't lead to
convictions so loads of the other
prisoners are going to be rapists too
they just weren't ever caught because
these are violent men who are willing to
break the law right some of them will be
rapists
tens of thousands of rapists right
you've got four thousand women roughly
three and a half thousand four thousand
women mostly in there for non-payment of
fines often TV license soliciting drug
offenses theft that sort of thing most
of them have experienced domestic
violence
you know most of them have been have
suffered very much at the hands of men
you know specifically
uh very few violent offenses and really
almost no sexual offenses and the sexual
offenses are often um in in partnership
with somebody else women who go to jail
for sex offenses it's often that they
worked with a man to create child
pornography
or you know they were soliciting they
were part of a brothel type situation
it's not because they forced themselves
on people it's hard for women to force
themselves on people
anyway so that's so you just
unbelievably different populations and
add to that the fact that men are much
much stronger than women
now you've got some men that you can say
what would you like would you like to
say that you're a woman and move over
there like men male prisoners are not
male prisons are not very nice like I
don't know how naive you have to be to
not think that this is going to lead to
some strategic decisions to transition
is it do you think they're not naive or
they just I interpret it as they don't
want to think like that so for instance
it's it's like you know the migrant
crisis where you hear somebody on on the
left go I think they should just all be
allowed to come here and you go well
you're not really thinking about the
long-term implications you're not
thinking about the impact that's going
to have on people you're not thinking
about the impact that's going to have on
what's going to happen further down the
line You're just showing your care for
people who are struggling I think that's
not a good analogy because you know
solving the migrant crisis would
actually take Serious efforts like you'd
actually have to do something and you'd
have to spend money and you'd have to
think about policies and you'd have to
accept you know maybe more or if you
were drownings but some drownings
whatever like it's tough tough choices
have to be made there's no tough choices
here we've got male prisons and female
prisons there's literally no problem we
were doing it the right way before I
think it's you know this word privilege
is is overused but it's mostly just
badly used it's privilege it's the fact
that the people who are talking about
this are never going to be there
themselves you are looking at the people
who are in the hardest situation in the
world when you're looking at some of the
prisoners especially these women in
prison you know these are women who are
away from their Partners their way their
children their Partners have left them
you know it's just people that you know
like I'm literally I'm never going to be
there
and so if you are attached to this
ideology for reasons to do entirely with
virtue signaling in my opinion uh this
is a very inconvenient thought the
thought that prisons are a place that
show that this was a bad thing to do and
the thing about prisons is you can lock
them off they're black boxers you can
just not pay attention to what's inside
them so they do you know it's it's a
price that you're willing for someone
else to pay well exactly right and I
suppose this is where the conversation
about erotic uh
the erotic side of it comes in because
are you arguing that there are no people
who who might be claiming to be a trans
woman who are also not a threat no we're
not claiming that at all no no I don't I
didn't think you were but I just wanted
to check yeah so I don't think that
trans women who are men are any more or
any less likely in general to be threats
than men okay right but then because
they are men exactly men are men commit
nearly all the violent crime men commit
nearly all the sexual offenses men are
much stronger than women but also it's
not just about threat like I think
whenever I talk about prisons to policy
makers somebody will say but how many
rapes are there or you talk about
changing rooms they'll say how many
rapes are there I mean we have changing
rooms and separate prisons partly to
stop rapes but also just because it's
kind of embarrassing undressing in front
of people of the opposite sex like
you know modesty is a thing and most
people feel more comfortable in Intimate
situations with people of the same sex
uh you know it's not that you Nest I
mean like if
in my workplace
if we were to switch to go
gender-neutral toilets I actually don't
think I work with anybody at The
Economist who would have caused me
problems I still don't want them in the
bloody changing rooms with me if they're
men it's that simple so yeah I mean
the reason I raise that point is I
suppose my uh concern there would be
that the a trans woman who is just a
trans woman yeah being forced to be in a
male prison yes makes her very fine yeah
you you make a very very good point
whatever you say whatever pronoun you
want that person is going to be much
more vulnerable as a result simply of
the fact that they identify as trans
well probably probably as a result of
the fact that they appear feminine or
female to whatever extent they do yeah
so that's that's an excellent point and
that points the way that we should think
about these problems
so you know if trans women are women
then trans women belong in women's
prisons whereas if we accept that trans
women are an unusually vulnerable group
of men well then we think how do we deal
with this unusual capable group of men
and actually prisons have a lot of
groups of vulnerable men young men are
very vulnerable in prison gay men are
very vulnerable in prison police
officers are very vulnerable so by the
way are pedophiles and other sex
offenders and this is not me saying that
trans women are sex offenders I just
mean that prisons manage very vulnerable
groups they may have to manage gangs
they try and keep drugs out you know
this is just another vulnerable group of
men and should be thought of that way so
for example perhaps a separate wing
will be a good would be a good answer
[Music]